welcome back to the 55th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour my name is tiffany
ma
and so far we've made sixty seven
thousand eight hundred dollars on this
episode
on this podcast oh wow she put a spin on
it
i hope it happens one day that would be
amazing
if you could make 67 000 for an episode
that was so much pressure i'm not gonna
lie really yes you did great that was
yeah i will say that's probably the best
one we've had so far
don't don't hype me up like that no i'm
serious no
jack rarely says that by the way yeah oh
thank you yeah thank you
well thank you so much for coming on the
podcast coming all the way from los
angeles
yes it was a five hour drive really wow
did you did you do that this morning
i did do it this morning oh we did that
too yeah
actually wait a second no yeah we were
an hour ahead of you
so we went to los angeles briefly
yesterday
just to support meet kevin he's running
for governor of california you got to
vote for me kevin
vote for me kevin but he was holding a
rally in venice beach
and last minute we decided it would be a
really good idea to go down and surprise
him
that's good friends right there i also
can't believe he's running for governor
yeah
and he's serious about it too people
were were actually messaging me
on instagram and saying i didn't know
he's serious i thought it was like a
publicity thing i thought he was doing
it for clicks
like no he's actually serious he's
really doing it he's running
do you know who the other candidates are
other than caitlyn jenner
uh gavin newsom oh well that makes a lot
of sense
do we say his name here do we say his
name i think it's his name okay
yeah we can bleep out the name as well
yeah kevin calls him
gruesome newsom why is that
this is not a he's not he's not a fan of
his opponent that makes a lot of sense
so we should probably give you a little
bit of an introduction
before we proceed graham you like saying
the story yes okay
so uh tiffany ma you are yeah so
you are a uh youtube influencer
yes yes and uh you posted a video
a long time ago maybe like what was it
two years ago probably
how you bought a 1.3 million dollar
house at 25 years old yes
and in that video i reacted to it
and i forget at the very end i i said
you click baited us
because you never told us the details of
like how expensive the house was
yes so you gave basically your entire
story of how you got started
how you made money from youtube you
saved it up you bought this house in los
angeles and it looked like a really nice
house thank you
so i reacted to it i'm like you didn't
give us all the details
then you made a video of what was it how
you spend was it how you spend your
money
um it's how much i spend in a week i
believe yes
how much you spend in a week i reacted
to that because in that video you went
down your houses
your house expenses and both of those
videos by the way did extremely well on
our channel
yeah they really did they were all one
better than mine i was like graham is
making more money
off of me than i am which is so
embarrassing it's embarrassing for me
it's not it's really good for you guys
so this this also happened with i felt
so bad for shelby church
she would put like days of work into
these videos that i would just knock out
like 30
minutes and the video that i would react
to in 30 minutes would like triple the
views of
shelby's original video and make like
double the amount
don't hate the player hate the game yeah
i mean mad respect for you for figuring
out that reaction videos
do so well so so we realized like wait a
second we're on to something because two
videos in a row
from your channel do really well so like
how else could we extract
value from this channel and we
what was the next one you posted another
video it was how much
i spent in a month as a homeowner yes
right yeah yes
yeah so then we did a third one yes so
yeah we're not gonna stop it two no
three four three man how much i spend in
a month
and that video exceeded our expectations
very well
really well and then you realize this
you're like you know what i'm gonna make
a response video
to graham so then you respond to me and
then i'm like
now it started because now that you
responded to me i got to respond back to
you you know what i was jealous you were
making so much money off me that i was
like i need to make money off of graham
somehow
smart it's hard and by the way all of
these conversations were happening
through youtube we had reached out like
briefly yes maybe a year ago
saying like oh you know we should all
describe dinner at some point uh
but everything else be on that was like
through youtube so i would
hear your response record myself
responding to you
post it on youtube then you would
respond back yes we did this like five
times
and it was very successful for our
channel so now
this is the first time we've met in
person this is amazing yeah so hi
hey so thank you so much the story
doesn't end there
oh let's continue you didn't force me
you uh you really tried to get me to
make a video that i was
really uncomfortable making but i did it
because you said
that i should do it and i said if i got
5 000 likes i would make it
which was but first i want to thank this
video sponsor morning brew
before i discovered morning brew my
morning routine consisted of me
endlessly scrolling through social media
or staring at elon musk's twitter page
to see what crypto he decided to plummet
that morning
but now i'm subscribed to morning brew
morning who come on graham i said
morning brew
oh duh morning brew oops i am so dumb
wait a second jack did you write this
script morning brew is a free daily
newsletter that's delivered
all week it catches me up on business
finance and tech news in just
five minutes traditional news is so
boring and with my tight work schedule i
need something that is easily digestible
and won't take me all morning to read
that's why morningbrew is relative
and informative while keeping it concise
and to the point which i absolutely love
something really helpful i've learned on
morning brew is that lenders have been
calling employers to confirm you're
working from home which is super helpful
because i'm actually looking to buy my
first house
and i really hope they don't call graham
they better not because i won't pick up
right anyways there is no reason not to
subscribe to morningbrew if you're
interested in business finance or tech
plus it's completely free and it takes
you less than 15 seconds to subscribe
seriously guys i've been using
morningbrew for well over a year and i
absolutely love them i read pretty much
every single newsletter every single
morning and i really want them to be
able to sponsor us again so
go and click that link in the
description go and subscribe you're not
going to regret it
and enjoy how much money i make in a
month
yeah that's right forty thousand dollars
a month
i feel like that's on the low end so it
was a sixty
sixty i thought it was forty no that was
kelly stamps
callie was forty gosh i've been
confusing everybody
sixty thousand dollars a month but i
feel like that would be on the low end
um it's gotta be so you know what it is
it's my sponsorships really fluctuate
which is the number one thing i hate
about
what i do which is why i would love if
the majority of my income actually came
from adsense because it's very very
steady no my uh some days i have really
really good months
some days i don't get paid for four
months later so
um is it the same for you because i know
you do sponsorships as well but do you
get paid three months later
yeah yeah so there there was one that
i'm never going to work with again we'll
bleep it out alex
to now yeah it has been terrible i will
never do them again they're a fantastic
product
but just bleep out they're a fantastic
product i actually
really like them but as far as having
them as a sponsor
we'll never do it again how long did
they take like four or five months
that's a
long time it's terrible that's bad for
you guys
that's bad four or five months yeah he's
your agent who's your agent
um so i was with wme but i'm no longer
with them and i just have a manager now
you should
i feel like it's not the brand's fault
it's the it's the agent's fault if it's
taking forever
um so the story i'm gonna say is
actually before i had an
agent or a manager and i used to have a
fake manager
i would send an i was smart but dumb in
some ways
i would pretend i would have a manager
so that i could actually ask for more
money so
my girl's name was lisa bates um i'd be
like
i'd get the incoming email and i'd be
like yeah let me send it to my manager
my manager's name was lisa bates i'm not
going to lie trying to make her sound as
caucasian as possible
um and she would be the one dealing my
deals
but which you were catfishing so you're
pretending to be
the man and i worked with massive brands
catfishing like i'm talking about
fortune 500 companies catfishing them
and then i finally got a manager but i
should have done lisa gates
or like lisa bezos schwartz or something
like that you know
i mean i i honestly i look back lisa
can't mess with lisa musk
what was that movie with christian bale
where his last name was american psycho
there you go
i think i just watched it i was like
lisa bates is it it is
um but we'll bleep this out um
you know didn't pay me for a year and a
half
and then they paid me wow it was a ten
thousand dollar brand deal this was
before i had a manager so
ten thousand to me was so much right um
they only ended up paying me seven
wow a year and a half later i don't know
i even emailed them
this is three thousand dollars short
they never responded wow
how do you land those like mainstream
media like
brand deals um you know what it is i
think it's because we're different types
of influencers i definitely am more of a
lifestyle influencer so i work with 17
magazine
vogue um target these
massive actual five fortune 500
companies
um and i think it's just the type of
content that i produce so
if you see my instagram i i think my
photos are
cute and good and i'm also very
relatable because
at the time i was in college and um
i don't know that's a really good
question i think that i think of that
every single day
i'm i can't believe target wants to work
with me especially since i cuss now
i find it very surprising let's let's go
all the way back how did you get started
doing all of this
uh it's a crazy story so
i was 16 when i started um i watched a
lot of makeup videos on youtube i was
like i think i can do makeup as well
i could not terrible makeup artist not
even a makeup artist terrible
makeup a player in general um
and then i graduated high school went to
ucla i was
consistently making videos maybe once
every other month
um my senior year of high school college
sorry
i got a full-time offer for sixty
thousand dollars doing
i was business economics i'm so sorry
i'm all over the place right now there's
so much to this story
um so my junior year between senior year
i had a summer internship
for one of a pretty big accounting firm
they gave me a full-time offer it was 60
000
and then that february right before i
was graduating
uh both my grandparents passed away and
i had a midlife
crisis so uh
i remember crying i actually called
tammy who's sitting over there i was
like tammy i don't want to do this job
i think i want to make youtube videos
full-time but the problem is
i only made eleven thousand or thirteen
thousand dollars
the year before that's not bad like
that's pretty good
that's true but going from sixty
thousand dollars in a cushy
career-driven job
where there's a corporate ladder that i
can climb versus
eleven thousand dollars i was like yeah
i don't know if i'm throwing away a
career just for youtube
that's an 85 pay cut oh that's good
yeah that's good yeah imagine that jack
85 percent less
you wouldn't be able to eat uh all the
fast food he's eating
well thank god that uh a year later i
was making six figures so
it ended up being wait so you went from
11 000 to 100
000 in one year on youtube how um
i grew so fast i think i graduated with
maybe
a hundred thousand subscribers and then
it grew to about six to seven hundred
so how much were you making with one
hundred thousand eleven thousand dollars
wow wait so so when you quit your job
what was that like by the way quitting
um i emailed the guy and i was like is
there any way i can defer my offer
because i actually technically didn't
start till october of 2015
after i graduated so we were able to
defer it to october 2016 because they
absolutely loved me i'm a
biggest i i love talking to older people
i'm just
i genuinely just like love to get to
know people so like all the partners
loved me and they were okay with me
deferring
and you just decided i'm gonna dive
headfirst into youtube yes
so you never rejected the offer though
you just deferred it i just
no i i accepted which is the biggest
no-no you can do at ucla they tell you
all the time that if you ever get a job
offer
never accept it unless you like don't
accept it
yeah um because it takes the job away
from someone else right
so definitely a mark on my transcript
there
but um i uh they
actually emailed me in july 2016 asking
if i was coming back and i said no
yeah so they're probably very happy how
often were you posting
like what was your once a week once a
week what was your financial situation
like
at that time like how were you able to
support yourself and
save and make youtube videos um but the
year after i graduated college
um so actually i convinced tammy to move
into
with me in a loft in downtown l.a
in skid row right behind cecil hotel wow
yeah
that by the way uh i think i watched
what was that it was on uh
netflix about the cecil yes it was a i
highly recommend anyone that wants to
watch this thing
it's a nail biter and i lived here right
there
wow yeah that was my view was this a
hotel for those that don't know the
cecil hotel is located
in this area of a lot of like transient
sort of people who come in and out a lot
and there are a lot of people who
go missing from this hotel just because
of the area it's located in
and the whole story was about uh it was
about a tourist
who stayed at the hotel and then you see
this footage of her kind of
going kind of nuts oh is that the one
yeah
like in the elevating in and out of the
elevator
yeah they find her in the water tank and
they try to discover
what happened to her and they try to
trace back like
where did things go wrong really i don't
want to give it away
crazy watch it there's a netflix
documentary yes is there a solution or
do they just leave it
like as an ambiguous it's like a 99
confirmed solution but like there's
maybe that one percent chance where like
that's not what happened yeah i've seen
like top 10 scariest
real-life horror stories like youtube
videos on your videos on youtube
yeah that's always like it was freaky
like watching her in and out of the
yeah freaking she was like looking out
of the elevator too
trying to hide and then they they found
like some like foot
so there may have been like someone else
there it's
watch it it's a good it's definitely a
good series have you been to this diesel
hotel um i have not but i watched by all
the time since i lived right there
but that's not even the scariest place
i've ever lived at
surprisingly i actually um i've actually
never told anyone this
i don't know what i'm telling you i'm
getting vulnerable we're getting very
we're getting deep
okay we're getting to know each other
right here shout out to the clips
channel
so you know what tiffany we actually
just made a clips channel for this
podcast
nice wow that's amazing isn't that
awesome that's perfect
yeah it's linked down below welcome back
from the sponsor
uh welcome back from the sponsor that's
right um so the scariest place i've
actually lived at
is when i grew up um i grew up in the
ghetto
so i i think a lot of my fans or
followers think i've
had a cushy life i didn't it um i grew
up behind a trailer park growing up
until i was about eight years old what
location was this
um so this is sacramento um and it's in
a neighborhood called broderick which is
actually one of the worst
um neighborhoods in sacramento so
yeah so i've seen some things growing up
as a kid what made
that part so dangerous scary
so there's gangs in that area for sure
yeah and then there were deaths and
drugs in the trailer park right behind
us so
i mean i grew up in section 8 housing
so i don't know if you're familiar yeah
so
um i mean my family was on food stamps
uh
i was living with my grandma with my
sisters at the time so i didn't even
look with my parents
which is very very common if you're
asian like in the asian culture a lot of
your grandparents will
raise their kids or your grandparent
will raise you
why is that because i've seen from from
my asian friends is they're all in one
household so it's like a
multi-generational household
the grandparents will live with the
parents who live with the kids but
is it why why do the grandparents raise
the children
um well my mom was an entrepreneur my
entire families are pretty much
entrepreneurs and thank god that my uh
my parents and my family
got us out of that situation but um
they actually moved to new york they
only took me weirdly
um and my old two older sisters were
still in sacramento and they went to
school out there um and then my parents
got divorced when i was
four or five and then i uh got sent back
to sacramento to live with my sisters
um and i think it's a i don't know why i
think it's very odd i would i could
never
give up my kid and make my mom watch
them but
you know i think it's a different
culture thing and it's a sure um
yeah i i can't explain why okay yeah how
do you think that
that childhood experience has affected
you today
um and your thoughts on maybe like money
or relationships or something like that
you you know what i see i think i'm good
with my money until graham stefan makes
videos about me and i'm like [ __ ] you
you're good with your money
you're good but i make everybody look
bad with them
a financial minimalist and i'd be like
wait a second they spent 15 cents more
than you needed to
yeah see i yeah i definitely think i'm
pretty good with my money um
i made a pack with myself when i was in
fourth grade to never ask my parents for
money ever again
so i have not asked my parents my
grandparents
anyone for money since i was like it
happened at fourth grade though
um you know what it is i hate to call
out my other sister my other sister
oh my god i hope you're not watching
this tree
um so my other sister is uh
she would always ask my parents for
things and she knew that we didn't grow
up with a lot of money so
i could just see the stress on my mom's
face and i'm definitely
very empathetic and i definitely grew up
a lot as a kid
i think i grew up really fast as a child
in the situation that we were in
um there's a lot more trauma with that
as well but
i just saw how much my parents struggled
that i didn't want to be a burden on
them
so not to say that they never gave me
money if they gave me money
i would never deny it it was just that i
would never ask for more on top of it so
like
if i wanted to go to on a field trip
that was 25
i made sure that was my own 25 dollars
that they had given me
prior it wasn't like i need 25 for a
field trip it was like
oh like thank you save and budget yeah
yeah um
so i've kind of been like that my entire
life
but you make me look terrible oh jeez
all right i'm calling you out
grandmother
graham's just a dress making all these
videos getting more views
it feels like relentlessly it's amazing
don't feel like i'm not trying to make
you feel bad i'm so sorry that's not
mine
so let's get back to so you're living
you're living uh around skid row
uh at what point do you do you leave
that area
move somewhere else um i only lived
there for a year because i was making
six figures and i was like i can't live
in skid row
although i will say i was never scared
to live there like to be quite honest i
never locked my doors like we had it
unlocked all the time
um but
my sister moved out she moved back to
sacramento and i moved to south park
which was kind of a more
bougier area of downtown l.a and i had
a really nice um one-bedroom apartment
for about i think it was about 2000
square feet for
i think it was 3 400. that was
definitely a splurge for me
at the time um i lived in la moore park
for
about a year after that and then i moved
to my spot now do you know where my spot
is
yeah it looked like uh we found we found
that on google maps or something
right yeah like around that because i
used to be yeah so i lived
uh in west adams and i've seen
all of the houses around the area oh but
i but i looked around all of those areas
i've seen everything because i was
obsessed with
just trying to find good deals in that
location and i was actually i was in
escrow briefly
i listed the house for like one five and
i got an escrow one 550
and it just had so many issues and the
seller was like giving me
shady information like stuff that that
if you were a seller you would have
known about these things but
but like i can't say that the seller was
like lying about it
but you should know if the house is on a
septic tank or not right
mm-hmm it's on a septic tank yes so
so there was a guest house that was
built on the property that
the seller said it connects to the sewer
line
so i said okay bro i'm gonna get my
inspection done
turned out there was no sewer line to
the guest house
the guest house was on a septic tank but
that whole area wouldn't permit for a
septic tank so the septic tank was put
there illegally
the guest house they had no record of
any permits ever being pulled for the
entire guest house
and they quoted this square footage that
included the garage
i'm like we don't include garage in the
square footage a lot of the house is not
on public record they had no
they had no record of this stuff a lot
of the renovations were done without
permits
and it was like ah so much like so much
this is like just
wrong with this property i asked for a
huge repair like a hundred thousand
dollars uh
a basic a credit back for all of these
issues and they told me no
so i backed out now the final joke was
on them because they ended up
res they then then the illness hit yeah
they took the house off the market i was
like
look at that took it off the market well
guess what they put it back on the
market
and they sold it for like one eight
during during this
sucker got it for 180 i wouldn't i would
not have paid that it was
listen it was a gorgeous house like
visually
when you walked in to me it was a 10 out
of 10. graham is trying to find the
photos of this old house
i um was gonna actually buy a house with
my ex-boyfriend
didn't it work out um why would you buy
a house with a with a boyfriend
um you know what it was just like the
next step it was like
the next step be getting married you
would think so in my head but in my head
i really wanted a house i really wanted
a house i was at the point where i was
sitting on too much money and it made me
really uncomfortable and i was like i
need to put this money somewhere
and i didn't know how to have that
conversation with my boyfriend where i
wanted it by myself so
it wasn't forced but it was like i'm
trying to be nice
and pretend that this is gonna work out
forever type situation
but he's amazing i wish him nothing but
the best but um
we were in else arena we found a
beautiful house
and we put an offer we were on we went
we were in escrow for about
almost two months because they could not
get uh
i figured out what the license is called
an occupancy license
occupancy permit oh yeah of occupancy
there you go yeah
they couldn't get that and i remember um
so while we were signing escrow i saw
this guy's name
who was the seller and i look i looked
up his name
and he used to work for the la city
council i don't even know if i should be
saying the story
and i found i find out there's a lawsuit
against him
because he tried to he was
he particularly illegal activities while
he was sitting on
the council so
either way um it turns out that once we
were gonna get the house
the neighbor was playing on sue was
suing us for
a land easement because the walls
our walls were on their land um
so they told us this two days before
we were closing on the house like two
days before we were putting money
in the house my ex-boyfriend and i were
literally sitting at wells fargo
the line was taking so long that we were
like okay we're just gonna
actually send over our payment tomorrow
it wasn't our it was like the rest of
our down payment like the other 17
of it um and
literally we uh the next morning we
found out we find out that
the neighbors were gonna sue us once we
got the house that's a blessing in
disguise
yes yeah and then we broke up a month
later so it was just like why'd you guys
what what happened what's
no now i'm i'm just curious what caused
the breakup nothing bad happened
it was um the
breaking escrow i don't know if that's
the right term
made me real it was a wake-up call for
me that you know like
things weren't weren't happening the way
i wanted them to and i was just kind of
going with the flow when i shouldn't
have been
yeah that's a blessing in disguise a
hundred percent
but yeah i'm with dave ramsey in this
you never buy a property
unless you're married with with somebody
else i would never
do that with like a like so you bought
this by yourself i'm guessing okay yeah
amazing yeah until you're married you
don't you don't buy a property with
somebody else
uh in colorado yes i don't know if you
saw that i was in colorado in february
for a whole month
uh when we were doing the back and forth
i was in colorado
we were out there to find a house with
my boyfriend
boyfriend another a different boyfriend
you're trying to find a house with a
boyfriend again
i don't i've never i mean hmm yeah would
you
i said i'd say he's the one for me like
he's the one the feelings i have how
long you guys been dating we've been
dating for three years now yeah
would you want to get married or is that
something it's it's more of just like a
like a
partnership um would we want to get
married
i guess yeah okay yeah i mean we've
talked about getting married for sure
um but for like next steps we both
wanted to
have a house in colorado for our future
kids
so i thought it was just good timing but
it turned out it was terrible time i
mean the market in denver colorado was
so hot
right right i don't know i'm i'm
maybe old school i think maybe marriage
yeah and then and then you buy a house
together so what about kids well you'd
want to have like i'd want to get
married first before having you guys
live together yeah you do yeah we live
together yeah but i was to say like if i
was to get have a kid right now
i wouldn't think anything of it yeah
yeah
i'd be like okay like our plans are
changing a little bit but that's fine
with me
i love the idea of getting married but i
don't need a ring on my finger at the
same time although
matthew if you're watching this i'd
still love a ring i don't know which
camera to look at i'm looking at all of
them
yeah if you do it make sure to do it on
the family vlog
yeah so we can monetize it
[Applause]
yes yes please so here you are today
60 000 a month where are you investing
it right now
where is it going oh man um i'm not
gonna lie i'm sitting on a majority of
it in cash and just losing money on it
i don't know what to do with my money
that's why i wanted to buy a second home
in colorado
well tech stocks uh just dipped and so
did cryptocurrency yes
you buy dogecoin at like under 30 grand
yeah
yeah yeah so why why do you want to buy
the property in colorado what would that
do
um so i want
i mean you've lived in l.a all the
schools in l.a
suck unless you live in
culver city or any of the other areas
that are really hard to purchase in
so i want kids in the future
not anytime soon and i just wanted a
good school system which is in
denver colorado my boyfriend right now
used to live in colorado so he
absolutely loves it and
i've fallen in love with it because it's
definitely a very outdoorsy space we can
go snowboarding
i snowboard so
i mean i just was like if i have
you know half a million in the bank
right now um i should
put it somewhere that will make me more
money so we were hoping to actually
purchase a vacation rental so it would
be like an airbnb but also our second
home at the same like a vacation spot
for us got it
i would diversify because you have your
house in los angeles yes
i think putting more money in real
estate in another location
would be a little bit too concentrated
on real estate really i do more stocks
yeah how much money do you have invested
in stocks right now um
i think about 180 one yeah
yeah i would get that up yeah especially
let's say if you have
five hundred thousand and well luckily
we're doing a video where you get to
spend ten thousand dollars of mine
wait explain it explain this to you
that's the video concept yeah
wait just spend it or invest it spend it
on myself
you're kidding me yeah no i'm giving him
ten thousand dollars to spit on myself
you're kidding
100 percent are you serious she's giving
you ten times i'm buying followers
because she's because she said like i
never spend money on myself
so i have one day to spend ten thousand
dollars on myself
are you kidding me no
no it's videoing oh my god i feel
terrible why
because we we made all those videos like
my
foot and then she comes here and she
brings toys for your pets and she's
giving you ten thousand dollars and
appearing on a part
podcast jeez oh my gosh
you were too confident monetization
oh my god that will be on my channel
make sure to watch it yeah
go to tiffany's channel it's linked down
below and you can see that video
of graham's spending money
for this me too are you guys going to
get in the car and go shopping and stuff
yeah we're going to go to gucci
i don't think we can afford anything at
romance for like ten thousand is that
expensive
hermes yeah yeah we gotta deck you out
with like an arames belt absolutely not
yeah
no absolutely the big h right there yeah
hermes is one of these spots where
everything just 10x the price of
everything
i thought louis vuitton was the most
expensive no no hermes
is one of these things where you have
you have clothing from
hermes that you know is from them
because it's so like out there and
vibrant
but they also have stuff that you would
have no it like that shirt
could be like air mass you'd have no
idea but it would be like nine hundred
dollars
but you would have no idea because
there's no logo there's no nothing on it
do you know what a birkin bag is uh that
i don't know what it is but i remember
uh that one guy alex alex pardo yeah he
like buys them but i don't know
what they look like or what the logo is
or oh it's just like um
it's a bag that's actually an asset
because it just appraises in value
oh yeah it's like a purse yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're they're made by hermes yeah oh
it's oh yeah oh i didn't know that
geez yeah they're nuts if you want to
spend 25 000
in a bag yeah that by the way i've heard
stories that you can't even go in you're
like they're like the high-end rolexes
you can't go in and be like
i want to rolex daytona they'll laugh at
you they'll laugh
you can't go in and be like i want to
buy a birkin bag unless you're like a
really good customer of theirs and
they're reserved so what do they say at
the door you like try to walk in
we don't have any available you have to
start by buying their scarves
they don't even let you buy their normal
bags because they have more than just
birken bags
but you slowly have to just build what
do you have do you have it from hermes
i see i'm so good with my money i don't
have anything how much does your outfit
cost
oh man vintage twenty dollars
um if we're not counting my rings
like fifty dollars sixty dollars that's
pretty good what about the rings
because they see one cartier i think uh
two cartier's
and one tiffany's and um
i'm not gonna lie how much are the nails
i did my nails myself
would love that yeah yeah mace would go
nuts over this i
thought that was like a hundred dollar
yeah that looks incredible actually
fun fact i used to want to be a hand
model when i was a kid because really
yes but no my nails have done it myself
no one's interested but i'm showing
jaqen and that's
incredible is that are those nails real
yeah 100 percent my nails
no yeah no they're not
they're not so those are that so they're
not like uh extensions those no there's
no way those are
those are not your actual nails i'll bet
you a hundred dollars those are your
actual yeah i'll show you
a um a video of my nails before
that's what i paint wait so you don't
have any sort of like
extension no what no
i have very healthy nails yes my nails
hold on is it you can see underneath
what oh my god it is wait there's
nothing let me see
there's nothing because you could see
the you know i can see the growth i
actually
only started coming to terms with the
fact that i used to be really poor
maybe eight months ago like really when
i went to ucla
all of my friend's parents i was the
only person i knew
that didn't have divorced parents hmm
all right that did happen that did have
divorced parents you're right
um and i remember not to call out my
little
i have a little and if you're familiar
with like sorority life or fraternity
life yeah
a little bro and a big sister and a big
bro and
that's the person like the year above or
below you yeah they're kind of your
mentor or your best friend depending on
your relationship so mine
is definitely i'm more of her mentor but
her her dad's very very successful
um like
ceo of like a fortune 500 company
successful
and she would tell me her monthly
allowance and i'd be like
how much was it i don't know if i should
say yeah i know no one has anything
no one's gonna know who this is i'm just
afraid if she watches it
but she but but you never said her name
that's that's very true yeah i mean
she's in my videos
they'll probably know but she gets let's
say it's like in the thousands
what but thousands could be like there's
a difference between two thousand
and six thousand thousand i would say
like like
low thousands like a couple thousand
three
that's still a hundred bucks a day crazy
that's amazing
so i'm in a sorority where everyone's
you're still in a sorority
well i'm an alumni now oh so i guess you
never leave the sorority
yeah although i wanted to leave my
senior year because i just thought it
was stupid
uh fun fact um i was treasurer my
sorority and we had monthly dues and i
wouldn't make myself pay
you make yourself pay oh they know
because no one would know
um so there's there's fees so it was 145
a month to be in my sorority and there's
like little fees like a late fee if you
didn't show up to a meeting on time
there's have you ever talked to someone
that was in a sorority
there's really stupid fees um if you
missed
dinner they would charge you fifteen
dollars for
about the leader of the sorority the
president yeah she would still have to
pay she didn't i mean she would always
be at the meeting because she's the
president i was vp of finance
so um i was in charge of i
i put girls through collection
like like actual collection collection
for sorority
and that wouldn't show up on a credit
report would it oh it did you're kidding
me
if they didn't pay their dues i'm not
laughing over there i think it was crap
how did you file that with
all three credit bureaus so they got um
they got three notices and i i had to
file it and that wasn't so you'd lower
the girls
but there's no way because let's say you
get a parking ticket that doesn't show
up on a collections if you just
never pay it it grows to some exorbitant
amount that wouldn't show up on a
collection
it's just you wouldn't be able to
register your vehicle after a year
there's no way it would that would show
up on a credit report because otherwise
what would happen is
so if i want to screw you jack i'd go
and file with the collection agencies
get that on the report you would dispute
it i'd be like oh
i don't have it and then it gets removed
but that puts you through a whole bunch
of stuff
otherwise everybody would just be like
you know what i'm going to screw your i
don't think you understand that
sororities are
companies we have like 50 000 members we
have a headquarters
i mean we were our
income in my sorority was probably three
to four hundred thousand dollars
just for my house who collects where's
let's say there's a profit who gets the
profit well it's a non-profit
yep but okay so we're just left out to
the
a lot of sororities and fraternities
were broke on at ucla's campus
we actually had money and we wouldn't
spend our money it would make me really
upset because i'm like i'm putting in
these dues but i'm not
getting the reward so we would spend
this money on not parties but like
get-togethers um kickbacks
like atrium no um we would renovate the
house
uh we had a beautiful home in holmey
park in
holby hills in ucla so beautiful home
but no i would legitimately send these
girls to collections
um and i would send their paperwork
their social security everything
to the headquarters of kappa delta which
was the company or sorority i was in
and then they would do that but i would
give them a three months notice so
one month 60 days 90 days and i hate i
absolutely hated it
to the point where i would literally be
like i just need you guys to have a
meeting with me
so we can talk it out and i will
literally take everything out but they
would refuse to have meetings with me
it just seems like you're getting like
indentured servitude
and then like you're also paying into it
and then
it i don't know but at the same time
they agree to
like when you sign up for a sorority
you're given the fees and everything
you're paying them and you're working
for them
oh me as a vp of finance yes i guess
was i getting paid anything no which was
why i wouldn't
make myself pay for stupid fees like
missing a party
or um i'd pay the monthly dues it was
more like
the t-shirts that were like 15 i would i
wouldn't even tell my friends that i
wouldn't charge them for it
like i just want to charge people for it
sometimes i'm gonna get in so much
trouble
but it's great this is seven years ago
it's fine
but going back to it yeah so a lot of my
sorority friends were very well off
and i was so embarrassed that i would
never tell them that i
i didn't have money i mean i was always
good with my money
so i always had money in a sense but i
didn't have their type of money
now it's weird now i feel like it's
almost a badge of honor not to come from
money
i agree now it's like oh yeah now start
it started from the bottom
now we're here true you know i think
it's drake that made us feel this way
yeah i think so what was your childhood
like
um it it definitely it wasn't i mean it
wasn't like
like growing up in the trailer park i
mean we're not competing in any way oh
yeah my childhood
bad was worse than that but it does seem
like sometimes there is that like oh
well i had it worse
yeah but uh no i it wasn't
it wasn't like it wasn't terrible uh
it's just
both my parents were patriot to paycheck
so it was just
uh there were a few months where
things were just like really tight or i
remember like my my mom would not have
money for the rent some months and would
have to like
you know pay over time just stuff like
that but uh
really supportive parents that's amazing
yeah is that
what made you who you are today because
they were living paycheck to paycheck i
don't know there was there was certainly
some of it but i don't i've always just
been
fascinated by money for some reason
because i remember even as a kid when
like
before i understood the concepts of like
uh like
not having enough um i was just i would
like collect
coins and stuff like that like i found
that really interesting it was my
grandpa who told me like there was this
1909 s
vdb penny that was worth like two
thousand dollars
when i was a kid i'd look at all the
pennies to see if like i could find the
1909 svdb penny
i've never found like you it's rare it's
almost impossible to find one in
circulation but i was
i enjoyed that um and just like
collecting things
um i collected tamagotchis you remember
those things yeah those are awesome
always dies yeah and uh and when i was
this would this would have been like
first grade i think so this was like
1996.
so yeah i would have been like six years
old i loved tamagotchis and i i'd
collect them
and like for birthdays or christmases or
like i would go see my grandparents we
go to toys r us i buy tamagotchi
i just collect them so i i had a
fascination always for like
money and collecting things what was the
weirdest thing you collected
um i guess everyone collected pokemon
cards so that's like that's not weird
tamagotchi is probably like the weirdest
thing uh oh for a while i collected
fossils i was obsessed as a kid with
fossils that's cool
yeah um i don't have any of them anymore
but like
like the stuff where like you get like a
little circle with like a leaf
print in it and like that was old i
still love those things
um collected fish and coral
that's not like that weird i mean you're
still collecting fish and corals
right for the aquarium nothing weird oh
uh i collected toenails
oh look on my face right now i was like
i don't know
i actually thought you were dead serious
because when we were clearing out your
place
yeah over on west adams yeah my dad was
sweeping the ground so we could sweep up
all the trash yeah and there was a
collection
of i want to say about 200 toenails no i
swear there wasn't no mine that would
have been italics alex look at alex
he saw it there there were so many
toenails that wasn't there were
so many like and and their classic bag
were just underneath there were cups and
stuff like on the ground so i was
wondering if you had a cup
like on the ch and not in the chimney
but like right on that fireplace that
got knocked
over and spilled all your collection of
toenails i swear and we filmed it too
but it was too gross to put it in the
vlog it was too gross i don't know if
you're joking or not so you
you have to like you have to swear on
both of your parents that you're telling
the truth i swear on both my parents i'm
telling the truth
i swear on both my parents put your hand
to your heart and swear i'm both your
parents i swear on both my parents that
i am telling the truth alex saw it there
was literally a collection
of like it was like a bundle of toenails
okay no i swear i'm gonna swear
it's not mine that must have been the
tenants what do your parents think of
all your success
and your grand and what what did your
grandparents think of the whole youtube
journey and
um my i feel like both my parents and my
grandparents
didn't find out about my youtube journey
until i was pretty successful so then
they were just very proud of me
but i will say i had a typical
upbringing where um
my family wanted me to be a doctor or a
lawyer
so i actually went that route ucla i was
pre-med and then realized i
hated all my science classes so then i
went business economics instead
but um yeah i came home from school like
doing extra homework on top of my
homework growing up
like think of tiger mom but
tiger mom oh no oh you've never heard of
the term tiger mom
imagine helicopter mom for
asians and instead of being super
controlling
it's controlling about your schoolwork
and
your grades um like i got in trouble if
i got a b
type parenthesis i got praised if i got
a c
are you serious if i got a c oh my
grades were so bad
that if i didn't fail it was a good
thing
are you kidding me yeah it was
throughout middle school
i i almost failed
so many classes they were like because
we get the report cards
it was usually like f f d f f how could
you do
i got a's in uh music and
english that's amazing and then
everything else was like d's and f's
and so i would get it to the bare
minimum by the end of the year
and of like a d or like a c minus at the
end of the year
and your parents wouldn't care would
they care uh they would care
but were never like you're grounded
or any i've never gotten grounded i got
in big trouble if i got bad grades
big trouble so i had to get good grades
yeah you know i just was so checked out
i hated it i couldn't
i don't understand how you could make
that decision though being 13 years old
or whatever didn't get a point
didn't did not get the point but i feel
like you don't need to get the point at
12 or 13. like you kind of just go with
the flow that's just a normal 13 year
old mentality just didn't like it
12 13 so yeah so 12
6th grade sixth grade 68 was 12. yeah so
i would have just gotten into the whole
like aquarium thing
and i was spending all my time online
and i just thought like
that's oh i think back then briefly i
wanted to be a marine biologist
i was like i don't need anything my
sister wanted to be a marine biologist
yeah so i wanted to do that but yeah i
was just getting into the whole like
reef aquarium thing and i'd spend all my
time online i'd
finish school go online on
reefcentral.com just chatting with
people about aquariums
so you weren't bad at school you just
didn't care enough hated it
yeah i just i hated homework just didn't
see the point but
i went to a really weird elementary
school it was called smash
in santa monica and it was this is
stanford santa monica
alternative schoolhouse oh and
we didn't have grades uh for it and i
went there until fifth grade
we had no grades we had really no like
formal education
our classes were straight up like let's
sit in a circle and talk about how we
feel today
and just like let's talk about like you
know
anti-gram what to sit in a circle and
talk about how you feel you got all that
out as a kid
yeah but you know what but we didn't we
didn't have homework
we didn't have grades and i don't know
what we learned
we we it was more like a social school
where they just
talked about like what what are you
interested in oh we could talk about
that in the circle we'd have the talking
stick and we said like
you'd have a talking stick and like now
you share something about yourself and
then the kid next to you goes and
i prefer that so to go from that to a
place where it's like oh
crap we have like an assignment i have
to set it to desk oh that was the other
thing
at uh at smash we never had desks
it was a big table and you could sit
wherever you want it
i liked that so was that transition from
smash to normal schooling is that why
you did so terrible
probably i just hated it but i liked
smash i liked the aspect of this
there are you turn into work and as long
as you like applied yourself
you're fine do you know how the kids
that went to smash turned out relatives
almost everyone turned out not not
successful but everyone is doing
something unique stuff
yeah um i would say
i'd say most of them turned out really
well and did they struggle once they
assimilated with normal school as well
uh some of them really transitioned well
and some of them didn't
um but yeah no we knew some really smart
kids
um from smash ended up going to like
harvard
and yale and like ivy league schools and
other people just pursued their own
thing
but yeah i attribute that to um kind of
just thinking outside the box
so that's what i like i don't know if
this is a rumor but did you once say you
dropped out of high school and then
finished your ged or am i imagining this
uh technically i guess it doesn't matter
now technically i never graduated from
high school
so i never did a ged oh wow but
technically i
failed i think it was i failed uh it was
a spanish class
and in order to get in order to get my
diploma i needed to have finished that
class and i was like one credit short
and i just didn't see the point of
taking that class over
over summer so when we did the
graduation they handed me a blank piece
of paper
but they still let you walk yeah let me
walk but they did not give me a diploma
so
i guess technically i don't have a high
school diploma technically but like i
i did everything it just minus the one
spanish class that i just was like
didn't want to take it wait when you
walked physically on the
through your graduation they didn't hand
you anything no they handed me a piece
of paper like
everyone got a diploma but mine was not
a diploma it was a piece of paper dude
i didn't get a diploma either i got a
piece of paper i got a piece of paper as
well
i didn't get it why did you get a piece
of paper i mean i got my diploma like
afterwards but
on the actual stage it wasn't a real
diploma it was just a piece of paper
oh as far as i'm aware everyone got a
diploma everyone did i was late on fees
so i like after they did all that i was
like in my cap and gown i had to walk
down to the bookstore
and pay fees and they're like okay
here's your diploma you know
not everyone needs school i i graduated
six years ago i still don't have my ucla
diploma it's a forty thousand dollar
piece of paper that i
what am i gonna do with it it'd be cool
to put up on the wall
no like that's expensive piece of paper
that's true
yeah i'd rather have forty thousand
dollars on the wall
um yeah imagine right like a little
montage
yeah where do you see your career going
do you see yourself making youtube
videos forever
uh i don't know i i'm not sure
part of me feels like i mean at least
for the next few years yes
but i like i admire the career of like
dave ramsey
look up to him a lot um judge judy
love judge judy dr phil joe rogan
i i love them and so like if if i were
to have the perfect career it would be
like judge judy
i think just having like a 30-year long
40-year long career
highly respected no controversies
everyone
loves judge judy i i want to be like her
you know that show's fake right
white jedi yeah no it's not what's fake
about it
those are actors no yes no there's no
way
oh i don't want to verse your bubble
there's no way you didn't just tell him
it's fake no it's not i don't believe it
i don't really it's
you're telling me like santa claus isn't
real i don't believe
it i don't i really i don't i'm gonna
look this up
i don't think so my understanding with
judge judy is that the settlements um
they're real cases
the settlements are paid for so like
when somebody owes
like thirteen hundred dollars because
they appeared
because they appeared those things are
paid i would believe that she's a real
judge
yeah she's definitely believe that uh
the situations were real
i would think that for a like a
courtroom setting
you can't do that and for like a tv
series and so it's like
these aren't maybe real legal cases but
the real situations that judge judy is
is doing like mediation or something
right she could technically be like a
mediator
it's arbitrator i think yeah here we go
next level so this
morris law center says the case you've
shown are real cases with participants
being
persuaded to give up their lawsuit in a
real in a real court of law
the courtroom audience members however
are reported to be all paid actors
judge judy was once a real judge but now
his arbitrator a very high paid
arbitrator okay
so it's basically arbitration um
and the courtroom audience members are
actors but the situations are
real and the cases
are not legal lawsuits but they are
that's interesting
real situations so i'm glad i didn't
burst your bubble so it's
still how you think of it yes correct
okay cool
just like by the way jerry springer
apparently uh
there are reported cases of people
pretending on jerry springer just to get
on
right but apparently my understanding is
they do their due diligence and they get
real people on but they pay all of their
expenses so people
are like incentivized to go on there and
play it up for the camera
but they are real people do you plan on
making youtube videos forever
um it's a good question
um i'd love to
but not just for the money how do i
explain this
um i would love to keep making videos
for the memories more like when i have
like my kid or i'm getting married
just so that i can look back on these
videos in the future i definitely want
to do more vlog
type style videos than anything else
but my real main
goal in life is to actually start my own
business and to become an angel investor
and i just don't know how to break into
becoming an investor in other companies
just yet oh gosh
it's a it's a crap show because you're
in
you're in a couple correct are you
allowed to say which one four of them
five of them um
yada bank was the first one um all i
could say a few of them
oxygen bank was another one uh
juice was another one that was with mr
beast's company
okay oh gosh there's there's two other
ones
um anyway uh there's there's two other
ones
at first i was like wow this is so cool
you could go and it'd be an
angel investor and then you begin to
realize that
there's so many of them out there and
they'll pitch you every day like once
you invest in one of them they're like
ah
it's like it's like a shark smelling
blood
and now it's like every day hey we got
this company we got this company we got
this thing we got this thing
and it's and the more i'm realizing like
it's a lot of
out there and everyone wants you to
invest
because then they could say graham
stefan invested in this
and this is a big wake-up call because i
i invested in
one and immediately after investing in
this one
they used my name as like oh gram stefan
is an investor in this
uh and so now i'm like now i'm like
really careful knowing that if i invest
in something
they're gonna use my name to get more
investment
just because yeah i put some money in it
so i don't know
i think if you really like the company
sure but
they just they just want your money at
this point
and the valuations sometimes make no
sense there was there's one
it was like a stock thing and they
wanted like a hundred i think it was
like a hundred
million dollar evaluation for something
that was
i think they had like if 30 40 50 000
members on it
but like they weren't making money but
they wanted a hundred million dollars
right
and people were buying it up so is it
something that you think
would be lucrative for you carrot that
was one of the
company the carrot credit card that was
gonna come that
yeah that's working out for you or not
working out no no that was just
one of one of the other companies that i
have yeah
carrot is one of these things where i
like i'm skeptical on their ability to
make money
long term but their ability to provide
value
but they're providing so much value and
i like eric eric is the creator
and i'm like i'm investing in eric
because i really believe in him
but i just think for eric is given too
much value so that that's my only thing
is
carrot is is giving so much to the
creators who get the credit card oh
if you want the credit card i'll give i
could get you the credit card
i'm not gonna lie i don't know what
carrot is you don't have your wallet on
you right
no it's just right up there i can grab
it alex do you have your credit card
with you
no and you can personalize it yes you
could personalize it
and i don't know if i can't promise this
is gonna happen but
eric so far has like personally
delivered
these credit cards like he shows up and
like here's the credit card i'm like
eric he didn't have to do this because
he just likes meeting everybody
so eric is beautiful so yeah so i will
if you want that credit card i would get
you the credit card
yeah okay okay so anyways that that's a
comment what are the benefits of carrot
what's yeah so they three percent on
three categories that you pick
three five percent i've only received
three okay well
i don't know but yeah it is it is
advertising you get to pick the category
yeah so i picked camera equipment
electronics and auto
which would be gas or yeah i think mine
is like five percent cash back
i think mine's five percent cash back
dining percent cash back electronics
three percent cash back i forget what i
mean so i will definitely be getting
carrot
yeah yeah it's very good that is crazy
yeah and then they had
special because here's the thing like i
took advantage of this
they had these deals where it's like one
day only five percent off everything
and they told me this like 48 hours in
advance
at the end of the year so i maxed out
the car there was like
i think they i think they gave me a
seventy five thousand dollar limit
i spent seventy five thousand dollars in
one day to get the five percent back
you know you can just put more money
into your card what do you mean
like so i only have one credit card i
need to get another one but my limit is
twelve thousand dollars and if i know
i'm gonna spend more than that i'll just
prepay so that it's like negative three
thousand
so this this is different this you link
to your bank account and every single
like on
on a set day it'll pull the money
automatically from your account so you
can't just choose to pay
early no and and plus that wouldn't
that wouldn't uh post on the same day
so even even if i were to max it at 75k
and then pay it off 75k and then max it
out again
i don't think all of that would happen
in the same day but i prepaid
like property taxes on there i bought
the refrigerator
that day i bought the piano that day
everything that i was planning to buy
i purchased that day i expect once i get
the carrot you need to tell me 48 hours
in advance when it's five
days you know they'll say oh they didn't
just tell you they told
everyone yeah 48 hours yeah yeah it was
like a black friday deal it's like hey
for this black friday everything you
purchase is gonna be five percent off
so i was like all right you sure all
right well
i mean because like going crazy paying
for your property taxes it's a three
percent charge for credit cards no
it's uh it was like one percent
something
then oh my god one or two percent yeah
it it it would it made sense for me to
try not making any money
that's what i said and i'm like but you
know what maybe it's only temporary
maybe they're not going to do it anymore
well after seeing what you did they're
probably not doing it i'm a good beta
tester
i need to talk to you about all of my
finance questions i feel like
yeah yeah well um next question i guess
would be uh how much more money should i
put in the socks
because right now it's scary i know what
i'm you know what it is
i have diamond hands but too well i
don't know how to sell stocks
that's what i need to sell you don't
need to sell ever but didn't you just
sell
doge we don't talk about that it was it
was too great of an opportunity it would
have gotten yeah cut in half
i've been telling all the money i put in
it would have got cut in half if i
didn't sell i mean i have doge
and i was looking at it when i was at 70
cents and i was like it's not going to
go to a dollar but i don't know how to
sell it right now
you don't know how to sell it's the same
thing as buy but just like the other
that's what i said i have diamond hands
but with bad companies i'll
stick with bad companies because i'm at
that point i'm like well
i just don't want to sell it where are
you invested now you're 180 do you want
to know yeah i do let me see it's all in
robin hood
it is uh it is all in robin hood
i can screen record oh my god i cannot
believe i'm showing you guys this
um so step one get it off robin hood uh
i disagree
you use robin head i like it i like
robin hood yeah
i download public and weeble yeah both
because of you you're not even on weeble
anymore i am
but you just don't talk about it anymore
public i
i may have invested in public ah
another one okay that makes sense um i
like public
uh public has the advantage of not
routing your order
flow so with which robinhood does so
when the whole fallout happened with
with gamestop
public was very vocal that they don't do
that
they don't route your order flow they
don't sell your data to hedge funds and
all right let's check this out yeah i
like i like weeble though
weeble in my opinion has one of the best
most sophisticated interfaces out there
for
for serious traders public is better in
my opinion for a long-term investment
that you're going to buy once and hold
for a long time
i'm gonna make let's see a really bad um
like connection i would say robin hood
is like apple where the interface is so
simple
weebles is so difficult to learn yeah
you actually
have to learn how to do that yeah all
right so tesla
let's see so you bought average cost
wow congratulations average cost of
tesla 195 dollars
yes you're gonna keep that okay don't
sell that is there any reason why you
have
like the little icon next to the stock
as the price of the share rather than
total return
i just like knowing what the price is
shopify great buy shopify
great buy great bite apple
fiverr let's see what you bought fiverr
at fantastic
uh beyond this is the only one i think
beyond i'm
yeah okay so so you're beyond meat is
the only one where i would be
i mean if you sold it i wouldn't be
upset
over that because it just i felt it was
a little hypey
uh ultra beauty never heard of this ulta
um one of the biggest like makeup
department stores
okay over stock great
you did well zoom let's see what do you
buy zoom at 306. all right well
i i keep zoom spotify 207
disney fantastic i don't even need to
look at that wow you bought virgin
20 okay virgin is like eh where are you
getting all of your
advice from um nowhere
you're just doing this on your own yeah
see i just look into companies that i
would naturally use myself
so then i purchased their stocks
you did well there's nothing in here
that
oh scroll down just scrolled that's some
of them are pretty bad
delta um aurora cannabis is so bad
lemonade you bought lemonade yeah that's
a hypey one
lemonade i think that's happened i
personally have lemonade insurance
that's why i got it snap has done really
well average cost 23.
um paypal i like it so far
mcdonald's a lot of these are the free
stocks that i got so if you see like a
bunch of random stocks at the very end
it's just i don't see anything in here
gap
i don't see anything in here that's like
oh wow i can't believe you have that
yeah i don't see anything in here that's
bad
i like it actually i would i would say
you did really well on this my only
advice would be to
just start buying what's your look like
oh do you want to see my crypto yeah
yeah
oh wow you have a lot i you know i
bought every single one that was
available on robin hood because i was
like
might as well just smile nice
six cent average cost on dogecoin wow
and you had
how much dodge could you have 20 30 000
ethereum so should i sell my dosh
points i would at this point just hold
it just hold it yeah
how much are you spending are saving
every year on your taxes
by living here probably four to five
hundred thousand dollars
just to live here so that that's why
like everything here is
in my opinion free even the car that
would have been 30
something thousand dollars of sales tax
to pay for the car that's your small
tesla
nothing no sales tax here
there's no sales tax used used private
car
a party car purchases no sales tax what
so it's got to be private party
and used if you buy this from a
dealership they're gonna they're gonna
charge you like seven something percent
private party nothing hmm that's crazy
yeah do you have a really good
accountant uh
she's good but i think my taxes now have
gotten to a point where
this year i'm probably gonna need like
like a a team
probably yeah it's just now things are
getting so nuanced
that um she's been really good up until
this point
where i feel like does she [ __ ] up no
it's just
i i think i know the amount of money you
could be leaving on the team yeah why
not i think i need something a little
bit more sophisticated at this point all
right it's just
everything is so nuanced that that even
for me i'm trying to research
stuff like this that i have no idea what
i'm doing now
now it's now it's it's in a league that
i'm just
i don't know how to navigate it i can't
believe you're saving or
saving 500 000 right that's what i'm
saying but for you too
you would be saving uh
60 probably 60 000 maybe
even we'll call it 50. call 50 50 000
and real estate is half the price
twice the size have you said how much
this house cost yet yes
uh one i paid one 440. what
yeah and then i put a hundred and
fifteen thousand in the backyard with
the pool
so i'm in at one five sixty one
uh and it's worth right now about one
750.
that's crazy that's impressive right but
this in los angeles would be like
three mm-hmm yeah and it's in a gated
community
which is nuts it was a really nice gate
yeah yeah i wasn't expecting that no it
was crazy too is that it's it
we're in an hoa obviously but we're in
an hoa within another hoa
so so this area is an hoa like
in itself and then this community is
another hoa
how are your hoas a month uh this one is
220 the other one is 110
i think so i think totals like 330 a
month wow yeah
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
thank you so much for coming on
uh we'll link to all of our information
down below in the description including
your channel
make sure by the way to get your free
stock worth all the way up to 50 on
public because it's pretty much like
free money and
even better guess what when you deposit
a hundred dollars on the platform
three people are going to get a chance
to win a completely free stock of tesla
three people how many people three three
times the number is before
and surprise i mean i can't give out
exactly how many people
took uh took me up on the last offer you
had a pretty good shot
at getting a free stock of tesla i think
people are under the assumption that
you know everyone's going to be doing it
uh
i was shocked i was shocked at the true
number of people who did this
so based on the last one it was it was
better odds than i would expect that's
all i could say
so and now three people are getting it
so deposit 100
on public enjoy get your free stock
thank you so much for watching
welcome back to this 55th uh
we're gonna have to do this again